I've been telling you for a while now
guys that Babylon 5 was not going to
appear on the CW and it would either
appear on Max or maybe even be sold to
Apple and it's looking more and more
likely that that's the case welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
just doing this really quick video on
some beautiful summer's day before I go
in and watch
um Fast and Furious X part one so it's X
then the next one will be XX if the next
one's XXX I think that's a different
type of movie but anyway before I go in
I just wanted to talk about an interview
that I've just seen with the head of
this CWU
umits she was talking to TV line and
it's been carried by a few other
articles now and they basically said
that the CW has already dropped several
projects and they've returned them back
to the studios they think can develop
those how they wish or sell them on
now she wasn't specifically asked about
Babylon 5 but with lots and lots of
other projects included it would seem
likely now they're basically saying that
a lot of these TV shows that used to be
developed in Partnership between Warner
Brothers and I think it's CBS was
reasonably cost effective but now that
the CW is owned by nexstar these shows
like Babylon 5 have all of a sudden
become quite an expensive proposition
so they don't want them they've spent a
load of money on Golf and things like
that and they want to basically get a
load of reality TV shows they don't
necessarily want a big sci-fi project
even Superman and Lois might be at risk
so it looks like something I told you
over six months ago I might be coming to
fruition because also the head of Warner
Brothers has been talking and last week
or so and he's been talking about how
they have a new plan moving forwards
with lots of projects that they won't
necessarily keep them for Max that
they're going to create TV shows and
sell them to other streaming services
because this is a really good way to not
only keep Warner Brothers Studios busy
but also generating income he currently
has got the entire Warner Brothers
turned around they've actually started
to make money again he's even been
talking about how they're going to stop
doing movies for streaming services
because not only does it not make money
it lowers quality so it looks like the
new head of Warner Brothers uh David
zoslav has actually got his head screwed
on and is actually thinking along the
lines we have that yes okay things were
bad during covid and they kept going the
best they could but now it's time to get
behind the cinema and also get behind
new TV shows like Babylon 5. Warner
Brothers is already making the new
Babylon 5 animated cartoon and that will
basically be sold on DVD initially and
on those you know those rentals
streaming sites where you have to rent
it initially
basically the same way they did have
been doing Batman for years it will then
probably appear on max
that if successful really does make the
chances of the new reimagined Warner
Brothers Babylon 5 series getting off
the ground
but most importantly it's a really good
commodity that somebody like apple would
pay through the nose for
so let's see what happens but once again
exclusively and first you heard these
stories on Sidetrack so tell your
friends because you know we do get a bit
of flack for uh people think we make
stuff up sometimes so you know it's nice
when the stories that we tell you a long
time ago start to actually come to
fruition
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new content
and as always please stay safe enjoy
this glorious summer if you're here in
the UK and I'll see you next time
[Music]